Venom and Spidey may very well meet on the
big screen again, but even with as much potential
as the clash could have, there are plenty
of reasons why Far From Home is far from the
right choice for another meeting between the
two.
Here's a look at the reasons why it probably
won't happen.
Venom's obviously much darker of a character
than Spider-Man.
Eddie Brock wouldn't let his symbiote kill
cops in Venom, but when it came to crooks,
he had a more fluid moral compass.
His solo film was PG-13 because the filmmakers
left a lot to the audience's imagination,
but make no mistake: He ate people.
Heroes kill bad guys in Marvel movies, sure.
Hawkeye's transformation into Ronin in Avengers:
Endgame was the darkest we've seen any of
their heroes go, but even then, no hero in
the MCU eats people.
With Disney's acquisition of Fox, there are
likely a lot of conversations going on behind
the scenes about content.
For example, we know Disney is interested
in more Deadpool movies and has pledged to
not water him down for younger audiences,
but it's doubtful he'll be part of the larger
MCU anytime soon.
Likewise, it will probably be a bit before
Disney gives the thumbs up to superheroes
who eat muggers.
One of the reasons Spider-Man and Venom's
conflict worked in the comics is that Parker
and Brock were in somewhat similar situations.
They were roughly the same age, they were
both journalists working for New York area
newspapers, and, largely because of Brock's
competitive nature, they were rivals.
The movie situation isn't the same.
In Venom, Eddie Brock is an established, adult,
investigative journalist.
Peter Parker hasn't graduated high school
yet.
Imagining the MCU’s version of Peter fighting
alongside someone like Venom is a little tough.
In the trailer for Far from Home, he doesn't
even want to talk to Nick Fury on the phone.
He's intimidated by Fury — so would he really
feel comfortable working with an oily pile
of black slime that talks like a gargling
demon?
Unlikely.
"On my planet, I am kind of a loser.
Like you.
But here, we could be more."
Spidey and Venom have met on screen before.
Topher Grace starred as Eddie Brock in Spider-Man
3, and he wasn't alone.
His villainous character was joined by the
New Goblin and the Sandman.
There were so many villains that Venom's eventual
appearance had to be held off until the end,
where it was rushed and unsatisfying.
In Far from Home, we've already got Mysterio,
and possibly Hydro-Man, Molten Man and the
Chameleon.
Not to mention all the rumors and theories
about secret bad guys.
Most of them will be no-shows, but it's still
clear there's no room for Venom.
Tony Stark has been an obvious replacement
for MCU Peter's absent father, and even Adrian
Toomes acts as like a twisted parental figure
in Homecoming.
From what we've seen of Far from Home, the
filmmakers have seemingly set up Nick Fury
and Mysterio as dueling mentor figures, too.
Fury offers tough love.
Since we know Mysterio is a villain in the
comics, he will probably be much friendlier
to gain Parker's trust.
Throwing Venom in the mix would give us one
too many surrogate dads.
Brock is, like most guys in this movie, older
than Parker, and has some abilities similar
to his.
Once they stopped beating each other up, Peter
would see him as another role model, and he's
already got enough to deal with in that department.
As the Far From Home trailer indicates, the
MCU we know might just be one small part of
a wider multiverse.
"Beck is from Earth.
Just not ours."
If this is true, and the MCU is about to open
up in a similar way to what we saw in Spider-Man:
Into the Spider-Verse, then maybe Venom and
the upcoming Morbius take place in a kind
of parallel world.
If Spidey winds up traveling through the multiverse,
one of the places he visits could be the world
where Venom occasionally rides space shuttles.
But there's also an alternate theory that
Mysterio is lying about being from another
Earth, and the multiverse has nothing to do
with what's going on in Far from Home.
While Mysterio presents himself as an ally
of Spider-Man in the trailers and TV spots,
he's one of Spidey's oldest villains, with
abilities involving creating illusions to
trick people.
It's totally conceivable he's not only tricking
Spider-Man, but Nick Fury as well.
If that’s the case, then it would seem to
close the door on the theory that Venom might
show up because of the multiverse.
The Venom movie not only divorced Eddie Brock's
story from Peter Parker's, it also established
itself as a force all on its own, inspiring
record-breaking ticket sales.
All those profits helped Venom establish a
strong start for its franchise, with advance
ticket sales even outperforming a number of
successful MCU movies.
Basically, the character has become an entity
all his own, independent of Spider-Man.
“You're welcome."
"No, YOU'RE welcome."
Introducing Venom to the crowded MCU now,
when he's just starting to make a name for
himself, could derail things.
His solo franchise would suffer if he's once
again seen as merely a Spidey spinoff.
Give Tom Hardy another movie or two with his
symbiote buddy, and then maybe he'll be ready
to co-star with Spider-Man.
Eddie Brock learns early in his most recent
comic series that his symbiote was on Earth
much earlier than he believed, and met a man
named Rex who had been merged with the alien
during the Vietnam War.
Venom met and battled a space - named Knull
who held dominion over all symbiotes, and
learned Knull had fought Thor centuries before.
Since these revelations, Venom's origin has
taken on a more cosmic scope.
If Marvel Studios wants to add Venom to its
movies, it may want to wait until it gets
the opportunity to introduce these newer,
grander aspects of his mythology.
There's already a lot going on in Far from
Home.
Knull, the All-Black, and everything else
would likely need their own movie separate
from Mysterio, multiverses, and Peter Parker's
newest crush.
Disney has a deal with Sony, which holds the
movie rights to Spider-Man and related characters,
for Spider-Man to be in the MCU.
That deal doesn't include Venom.
For the character to appear in a Marvel Studios
movie alongside Spider-Man, Sony would have
to agree to allow it.
When Marvel and Sony hammered out their current
Spider-Man deal, Sony's attempts at rebooting
the Spider-Man film franchise had failed.
They had a lot of motivation to work with
Marvel Studios.
That isn't necessarily the case with Venom.
In spite of being an utter disaster according
to critics…
"You are pathologically self-absorbed, your
ego requires constant attention, and you're
stubborn as hell."
...Venom made mountains of money.
And while the character is strongly associated
with Spider-Man, he isn't so strongly tied
to the rest of the Marvel Universe.
Arguably, as far as Sony's interests are concerned,
having Venom show up in Far from Home — or
any other Marvel Studios film — would serve
only to dilute the franchise.
So will we get more Venom?
Definitely.
Will he be teaming up with Spider-Man?
Probably not — at least, not yet.
"You gonna… you gonna eat anybody else?"
"Most likely."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Spider-Man
and friends are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.